ich habe hier auf meinem Kanal ja echt
schon viel probiert im Strom zu erzeugen
aber das ist glaube ich echt die beste
Idee oder die dümmste aber das wird sich
ausstellen was passiert wenn man Windrad
auf dem Auto drauf baut ich meine gibt's
jede Menge fahrt hin warum sollte man
den einfach ungenutzt davon kommen
lassen klar so ein Windrad wird
natürlich ein bisschen bremsen aber was
ist wenn man Weg findet wie das Windrad
und dann bremst und Strom erzeugt wenn
man vom Gas geht und ohnehin langsamer
werden will wie viel Strom wird das
Fahrt Windrad erzeugen kann ich damit
dann einfach alle Elektrogeräte
betreiben und wie werden wir das Teil
überhaupt realisieren können das
interessiert auch die Profi
Mechatroniker vom Volkswagen economy
Service von denen dieses Video
unterstützt wird und die bald hier drauf
reagieren werden also haltet die Augen
offen hier vielleicht wissen wollte ich
das Auto eigentlich gewinnbringen
weiterverkaufen da das aber nicht
geklappt hat habe ich mir gedacht machen
damit ich habe mir jetzt wirklich lange
überlegt wie man so einen Wind dran auf
dem Auto montieren kann und ganz ehrlich
war meine ursprüngliche Idee das einfach
direkt
hier aufs Blech drauf zu schweißen aber
wenn man eine Sekunde darüber nachdenkt
ist es echt eine dumme Idee vor allem
weil unser Volkswagen der gute Golf 5
Variante hier so eine richtig nice
dachträgerhalterungs-schiene hat also
habe ich mir hier diese universal
Dachdecker im Internet bestellt die bis
zu 75 kg aushalten ja und daran schraube
ich jetzt ein Holzplatz fest und zwar
meine alte Werkbank tatsächlich so und
dann einmal Schraube durch und dann noch
mal ordentlich fest
ähm Nikos wir müssen da leider
tatsächlich jetzt also ich brauche das
Teil also ich meine du bist ja süß und
so aber
[Musik]
so und dann ist einmal festspannen
top
so bombenfest geil unser Ziel ist es ein
Haushaltsgerät mit bis zu 1000 Watt zu
betreiben das reicht zum Beispiel für
zwei Gaming PCS 7 mal diese Fette
filmlampe oder einfach 60 von diesem
Kühlschränken zu berechnen wie groß das
Windrad bei welcher Form und welcher
Geschwindigkeit sein muss um 1000 Watt
zu bekommen ist gar nicht mal so simpel
und hat einfach zwei Tage gedauert
persönlich hätte ich einfach wieder drei
schräge Holzplatten genommen wie im
Video in dem ich schon mal ein kleines
Windrad gebaut habe aber Pascal meinte
dass das für ein Auto viel zu unsicher
ist und wir das lieber aus Carbon machen
sollten was ehrlich gesagt nicht nur
sinnvoll sondern auch viel geiler klingt
und jetzt kommt das ganze in den 3D
Drucker aber so ein Teil wird 60 cm lang
deshalb habe ich es in drei Teile
splittet einmal die Spitze einmal die
Mitte und einmal das Hinterteil so und
wie lange das jetzt dauern
anderthalb Tage okay nicht schlecht na
dann auf geht's
[Musik]
komplett geil das ist richtig heftig
diese Form sieht richtig krass man sieht
auf jeden Fall hier diese einzelnen
Polygone vom 3D-Modell ist auch nicht
schlimm da wird sich wieder drüber
geschliffen jetzt mal aus drei Tagen
erstmal noch ein Teil werden dafür haben
wir hier so Messingrohre die hier in die
Löcher reinkommt sondern schneide ich
mir mal eins ein bisschen zu ist einfach
ein bisschen kürzer werden
ganz grob so und dieses Messingstück
mache ich jetzt hier mal rein dann kommt
hier Sekundenkleber so dann mache ich
hier den Kleber drauf dann kommen die
Aktivator drauf
zum Zeug dass der Sekundenkleber
wirklich komplett direkt klebt und dann
wird es drauf getrieben und
top
so Aktivator dann kommt der PIN hier
rein
okay das ist blöd aber es hat viel
ausgehalten
boah das hat jetzt sehr sehr gut
geklappt das ist perfekt
[Musik]
ey das ist richtig cool so eine
geschwungene Formel kriegst du halt
einfach ohne 3D Drucker gar nicht hin
ich wüsste nicht wie man das machen oder
sollen jetzt denkt ihr euch vielleicht
ist das wirklich sein Ernst einfach so
ein Plastikteil auf dem dachschrauben
dass ich dann mit gefühlter
Überschallgeschwindigkeit dreht und dann
irgendwie noch abreißt oder so und dann
volles Blech oder sonstwem im Kopf fällt
habt ihr natürlich recht deswegen wollte
ich eigentlich auch aus Holz machen
pascal hat aber die Idee dass man
einfach das Ding aus Carbon macht
wodurch es nicht nur richtig stabil ist
sondern was auch echt einfach heftig
cool ist und genau das machen wir das
heißt das Teil ist ja eigentlich nur die
hilfsform und die komplette Stabilität
schafft einfach dieser Carbon Stoff und
das ist voll heftig weil man könnte sich
damit auch einfach ein T-Shirt stricken
gefühlt so ich breit das mal hier aus
das fühlt sich so geil an und lege jetzt
mal den Flügel hier drauf und dann
schneide ich mir das zu grob zu aber mit
einer Schere
kommt die große Rolle Weg so habe ich
jetzt hier Sprühkleber
das ist komplett krass
[Musik]
ganz schnell in den Augen ja
das ist wirklich jetzt einfach mal rein
jedenfalls in der Theorie
ich glaube sogar richtig gut ich fühle
mich echt ein bisschen den Schneider
[Musik]
das ganze doch schon mal sehen lassen
woah krass
[Musik]
das Ding wird jetzt also man kann sich
vorstellen dass wir das ungefähr
laminiert in so einer Folie und dann
wird da so ein Kunst hat durchgezogen
und das härter das dann alles aus es ist
echt super komplex und damit man dann am
Ende trotzdem die Carbonschicht von
dieser Plastikfolie trennen kann gibt's
hier noch eine Zwischenschicht und da
muss ich jetzt noch ein bisschen
schneidern
so das gebe ich jetzt einfach noch mal
fest mit dem Tape das ist hier so ein
stofftape aus der Apotheke damit ihr
später das kunsthase richtig schön
durchziehen kann auch
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich jetzt gerade grob die
Folie zu in der das später quasi ein
vakuumiert wird das kommt jetzt noch mal
in so ein Netz rein da wird auch so ein
Schlauch hier durchgefädelt der so
Löcher hat mir das Zeug wieder richtig
gut durchfließen kann mein Gott das
sieht aber zu Hause es wird da überhaupt
nichts warum kommen aber ja muss so hier
kommt die Dichtung und jetzt muss er
wirklich komplett dicht sein darf gar
nichts durchgehen kein bisschen Luft
darf dadurch kommen so finde ich gut
jetzt richtig einmal diesen Schlauch
hier ab so ein bisschen wie Knete
gleiche Spiel auf der anderen Seite und
auch ein Schlauch rein alles klar jetzt
machen wir den Deckel drauf wie gesagt
ihr darf jetzt überhaupt keine Luft
durchkommen das heißt es muss absolut
perfekt dicht sein
[Applaus]
um mehr zu testen ob das Ding dicht ist
mache ich einmal die Vakuumpumpe an die
ich da sehr angestöpselt habe die saugt
jetzt mal komplett raus
geil
boah das ist crazy wie ist das
rangezogen hat ja das auf jeden Fall
dicht aus geil so jetzt möchte ich jetzt
zwei Flüssigkeiten zusammen sind giftig
200 g von dem Zeug
und 60 Gramm von dem Zeug
[Musik]
ist ja die beiden Flüssigkeiten hätten
jetzt aus hier kommen jetzt der andere
Schlauch rein so diese Flüssigkeit wird
mit dieser Vakuumpumpe durch dieses Teil
durchgezogen damit alles schön
beschichtet ist mit diesen coolen
Schläuchen und Gitter und sonstwas und
deswegen sage ich mal feuermarsch ich
drehe jetzt hier quasi das Ventil auf so
was am Arsch da kommt geil das sieht
mega geil aus semeras geben noch und das
wird jetzt hier durchgezogen was hier
läuft jetzt gut durch eben durch dieses
Gitter hier sieht man schon wie das
richtig schön dunkel gefärbt wird
ey das funktioniert besser als ich
befürchtet habe und jetzt sieht man auch
wie das Teil hier als Autobahn fungiert
das einmal das ganze Zeug noch ein
bisschen schneller durchgeschoben wird
und nicht so lange braucht der Schlauch
hier crazy
[Musik]
die andere Seite sieht auch perfekt aus
und jetzt muss es 24 Stunden trocknen
damit das Ganze etwas schneller trocknet
haben wir den Flügel in die Sonne gelegt
und naja was soll ich sagen nach 30
Minuten ist das 3D gedruckte im Inneren
durch die Hitze war ich geworden und das
Marco rum hat dann den Rest erledigt
richtig ausgehärtet war der Flügel dann
erst weiteres gedacht nach 24 Stunden
und damit habe ich dann direkt mal einen
Belastungstest probiert
es trotzdem fest das Ding ist noch mal
kaputt kriegen safe geht das kaputt
oder
nie im Leben doch
[Musik]
das ist krass ne das ist krank
das war's also noch mal alles von vorne
und diesmal werden die 24 Stunden
komplett abgewartet
es ist trocken
das ist echt krass das ist echt krass
muss das hier noch irgendwie ab so
fertig komplett geil von der Seite
[Musik]
hübsche Sache und es ist mega krass weil
nach demselben Prinzip werden auch
Carbon Teile für Flugzeuge und
Supersportwagen gemacht ja und davon
brauchen wir jetzt drei
[Musik]
damit diese drei Flügel zu einem Windrad
werden braucht es noch eine Halterung in
die sie reingelegt und festgeschraubt
werden können
[Musik]
und schon können wir zusammenschrauben
okay und jetzt muss ich wieder überlegen
wie rum das ganze da reinkommt das ist
die hintere Seite heißt das ist die
vordere Seite bei den professionellen
Windrad können sich diese Winkel selber
einstellen glaube ich je nachdem wie
schnell der Wind ist und so aber hier
muss man es manuell machen was war da 10
Grad war optimal ich habe noch eine Idee
wie man die gleichmäßig hinkriegt dafür
brauche ich erstmal Wasserwaage jetzt
ist es so dass dieses Teil hier auf drei
Ecken Punkten liegt und wenn ich das
jetzt hier einmal so hinlegt müsst ihr
das natürlich genau auch im Wasser sein
einmal so und einmal so
dann noch mal so ein bisschen höher hier
ja perfekt und das heißt automatisch
dass alle Winkel gleich sind und dann
kann ich jetzt fest ziehen schön
gleichmäßig auf jeder Seite einmal fest
ziehen top
komplett bombenfest das Ding und einfach
riesig ich gehe immer ins Auto ran
halten also ich glaube ich glaube das
ist einfach komplett irre haha es ist
aber so groß wie das ganze Auto finde
ich richtig gut so jetzt ist hier eine
Mitte ein Loch und natürlich nicht
umsonst da kommt eine Achse rein und wie
sich das Ganze alles drehen soll und
das ist diese Achse ja ich lasse diese
Achse immer unkommentiert stehen die
wird auf jeden Fall nicht kaputt gehen
und die muss jetzt von der anderen Seite
eingeführt werden so rein damit
Hang oha das bündig geil also mit dem
Teil da passiert auf jeden Fall nichts
das ist sowas von extrem stabil das Ding
hier steht natürlich nicht in der Luft
muss noch irgendwo festgemacht werden
AUA dafür gibt's diese fetten Kugellager
so das sieht schon mal nicht schlecht
aus und da kommt jetzt das Gerät rein
okay ich taubnabteilung ist es ganz
anders
ja wenn man seine Zeitung hat sollte man
auch mal anschauen und schon haben wir
einen 1er Windrad komplett geil also
allein schon dieses anhört wenn man das
so dreht
Ventilator das ist auf jeden Fall schon
mal gelungen diese beiden Vierkantrohre
sind übrigens ein Teil des Windrad
gestellt das genau wie der windradflügel
auch in CAD am PC designt wurde und weil
wir damit ja rumfahren wollen ist es
auch sehr sehr großzügig ausgefallen
damit es auf jeden Fall allen
Belastungen standhalten wird aber
trotzdem ohne insgesamt mehr als die für
das Auto und dem Dachträger zugelassenen
75 Kilo zu wiegen
[Musik]
und wenn man alles zusammenstellt dann
sieht es auch schon fast fertig aus aber
hier hält halt noch nichts also ran ans
Schweißgerät so und damit das diesmal
auch richtig hält das soll ja immerhin
auf dem Auto halten wenn ich jetzt auch
zum allerersten Mal mit einem
wig-schweißgerät was
[Musik]
komplett geil geht noch schöner aber ist
geil die Oberseite machen jetzt auf
jeder Seite weil dann ist das schon mal
fest
[Musik]
eigentlich geile Schweißen hat geworden
bis auf am Ende darf ich irgendwie
verkackt und da ist auch ein mega Loch
drin und das weiß ich jetzt noch mal zu
[Musik]
das sind Turm
ja das ist jetzt nicht schön aber es
hält
[Musik]
so eigentlich waren hier zwei lange
Löcher geplant und zwar damit man diese
Lichtmaschine hier da nicht mehr
festschrauben kann sondern auch nach
oben und unten verstellen kann um diesen
Keilriemen zu spannen denn quasi das
Windrad in unserem Stromgenerator
verbindet jetzt dachte ich mir macht es
eben leicht und machst nur ein Langloch
weil hier reicht seine einzelne Schraube
und dann kann man ja quasi einfach diese
Lichtmaschinen nach unten und nach oben
rotieren und das damit spannen ja und in
der Regel funktioniert das damit auch
gut aber wie man hier sieht dürfte das
Loch dann hier keine gerade sein sondern
müssen den Kurve sein und drum
brauchen wir jetzt trotzdem lang noch
das hat man davon
wenn man sich Leben leicht machen will
Brille Micky Maus und ab geht's mit der
Stichsäge
[Musik]
ja das mag kein metallstich sehr Gewürz
heißt es ist auch noch ja das ist kaputt
aber gnadenlos AUA da geht gar nichts
mehr jetzt aber let's go
das geht ja durch die Butter
ich nehme das hier mal zum Kühlen
oje das ist ganz schön hot geworden
[Musik]
ja hat ein bisschen was von Dosenöffner
wie schnell das jetzt ging und schon
kann man die Lichtmaschine hier
wunderbar nach oben und unten verstellen
und dann eben erst hinterher
festschrauben
muss irgendwie mit dem Generator LKA
Lichtmaschine verbunden werden dafür
gibt es dieses geile Teil hier um das
dann hier so ein Keilriemen drum
gespannt wird und wenn sie jetzt quasi
das Windrad dreht dann dreht sich auf
der Keilriemen und gibt die Energie eben
eine Generator jetzt ist es allerdings
gar nicht so leicht das Teil hier hier
drauf auf dieser Welle zu zentrieren das
ist genau mittig ist pascal hat jetzt
die geile Idee einmal Adapter dafür zu
drucken in 3D Drucker den kann man die
einfach mal so ein bisschen drauf
stecken so und jetzt kann man das hier
einfach drauflegen und es ist
automatisch perfekt zentriert und damit
es auch hält weiß ich jetzt einfach an
[Musik]
und
jetzt räume ich erstmal die beiden
flanschkugellager hier fest
aber natürlich das Windrad hier durch
und zwar so lang bis das Teil hier und
das Teil der auf einer Höhe sind damit
ich den Keilriemen rein zischen kann so
und jetzt durch das Absenken das
Generators wird quasi das hier gespannt
und ich hoffe ehrlich gesagt auch dass
es genug gespannt wird weil es sieht
schon knapp aus aber funktioniert die
Lichtmaschine ist übrigens das gleiche
Bauteil das in dem Auto dafür zuständig
ist die Autobatterie aufzuladen und
damit z.B die Klimaanlage oder eben die
Scheinwerfer zu betreiben das gleiche
machen wir auch nur das nicht der Motor
die Lichtmaschine antreibt sondern unser
Windrad dieses Messgerät misst den Strom
der dabei entsteht und sendet dann in
Echtzeit auf dieses Display wie viel
genau gerade erzeugt wird gespeist wird
diese Strom in eine extra Automatik
unten Wechselrichter verwandelt den 12
Volt Gleichstrom aus der Batterie in 230
Volt Wechselstrom genau wie aus der
Steckdose damit können wir dann alle
möglichen Geräte betreiben
[Musik]
ja also das ging flott da ist gar nicht
mal so schlau war ein einzelnen Vögel zu
lackieren wird der Rest im bereits
zusammengebauten Zustand fertig lackiert
[Musik]
so wir sind jetzt auf dem
Verkehrsübungsplatz Auto steht da wir
haben richtig viel Platz und das Windrad
ist noch im Kofferraum ein bisschen
lustig auch so gegeben und das müssen
wir jetzt eben aufbauen und da bin ich
gespannt ob das jetzt mal klappt
einmal das dicke Windrad da war kurze
Stimmbruch
so das wieder einmal durchgezimmert
[Musik]
das ist doch komplett geil
und damit drehe ich jetzt eine Runde
oh mein Gott geil
es dreht sich also es dreht sich auf
jeden Fall die Frage sind jetzt noch ob
man damit auch Strom machen kann
es ist komplett geil es dreht sich
einfach es ist nicht runtergeflogen als
erstes müssen wir jetzt quasi die
Autobatterie am Windrad festmachen hier
die Masse also der Minuspol
so gut fest dann nee das ist so gedacht
ne so das Fest dann einmal plus
das ist bombenfest deine Minuspol so der
ist auch fest der Wechselrichter hier
verwandelt dann die 12 Volt Gleichstrom
von der Autobatterie die man halt nicht
für irgendwas nutzen kann in 230 Volt
Wechselstrom oder einfach Haushaltsgerät
anstecken
okay ja gut so schauen wir fest einmal
umgedreht haben wir hier zwei Steckdosen
und da würde ich sagen checken als
allererstes mal einfach eine filmlampe
rein damit die Lampe angeschlossen die
hält gerade Pascal ich habe dieses tolle
Strommessgerät hier wo wir sehen wie
viel Strom produzieren jetzt mal hier
unten hin und dann geht die Fahrt los
wir sind auf Übungsgelände ne oha da
kommt was oha oha wir waren jetzt aber
länger mal 80 Watt drauf ne aber
konstant 80 Grad Frank schon so zwischen
70 und 80 das heißt wir müssen noch
irgendwas machen damit ein bisschen
besser dreht und ich bin auch gerade 70
km/h gefahren und viel schneller können
wir auch nicht werden das heißt wir
müssen irgendwie an den Rotoren die
effizient steigern und dafür Kette jetzt
aufs Dach und verstell dir ein bisschen
es muss irgendwie die Nase weg war
wichtige Schrauben so nehme ich mein
professionellen Hammer
damit wir wieder diese
Dinger hier verdrehen können und die
müssen steiler anordnen können damit
hoffentlich mehr Energie aus dem Benzin
jetzt immer wieder fest so jetzt die
Kappe wieder drauf
ja als nächstes funktioniert wir
verstellen das einfach noch mal und
machen es nicht steiler sondern flacher
und probieren es dann noch mal
besser
ungesund gut
aber damit eine Lampe antreiben können
so und jetzt gehen wir Vollgas
wie viel Watt
das ist schon mal geil okay wir haben
jetzt bei 60 km/h ungefähr 200 Watt das
ist nicht ganz zu viel wie die 1000 Watt
die wir eigentlich berechnet haben aber
das Geniale ist ja dass wir eine
Batterie dazwischen haben das heißt wir
können jetzt einfach ein bisschen
rumfahren damit die Batterie voll laden
und uns mit dem erzeugten Strom
hinterher Waffeln brutzeln Strom mit
Fahrt hinzu generieren funktioniert zwar
und sieht mega geil aus aber ist
natürlich streng genommen und klug denn
die Energie die das Windrad aus der Luft
zieht muss das Auto ja erstmal mit
seinem Motorrad zusätzlich reinstecken
gewonnen wird hier also nichts aber es
gibt ein Ansatz das Problem zu umgehen
wird dieser kleine auf dem Gaspedal
festgeklebte Taster nicht gedrückt
bleibt die Batterie durch dieses Relais
vom Generator getrennt saugt am
Generator nämlich kein verbraucherstrom
ist es tatsächlich viel leichter das
Windrad zu drehen anders formuliert es
nimmt dann deutlich weniger Energie aus
der Luft seine Bremswirkung auf das Auto
ist also eine Theorie recht gering nur
wenn man vom Gas und damit vom Taster
geht und ja ohnehin langsamer fahren
will verbindet ein Relais die
Lichtmaschine mit der Batterie das
Windrad speist Strom in die Batterie und
bremst dadurch das umso mehr und zwar
nur dann wenn man eh langsamer werden
will ob diese Rechnung in der Praxis
aufgeht und sich das wirklich lohnt was
glaubt ihr auf jeden Fall haben wir
jetzt hier gut Strom eingespeist hier
sind zwei Steckdosen am Tag machen ich
persönlich denke da an was denn es geht
das hier ist auch schon warm mache ich
also nochmal ein bisschen ich habe keine
Ahnung ich will nicht dass das überläuft
ne
[Musik]
nein
stimmt perfekt
oha das sieht komplett geil aus also
wenn jetzt die beiden verkaufen
zusammenlegt sieht's aus wie eine
richtig schöne Waffe okay Prost
geil eine Waffe mit mehr oder weniger
selbstgemachten Strom das ist so dumm
war lecker tatsächlich noch ein bisschen
durch und jetzt weiß ich nicht wie
schlau das sind nachdem ich hier schon
eine Sauerei gemacht habe aber man kann
ja auch einfach einen startmixer
reinstecken und dann hier eine Banane
reinwerfen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist echt komplett so real jetzt
einfach alle möglichen Elektrogeräte
betreiben zu können
geil mal schauen was die Profis vom
Volkswagen economy Service zu diesem
Video zu sagen haben weil sie am täglich
mit Autos zu tun und werden bald hier
drauf reagieren die verbessern nämlich
ständig Gebrauchtwagen und ob sie das
als Verbesserung ansehen werden mal
schauen und ich glaube vor allem meine
schweißkünste werden da nicht unbedingt
den besten Eindruck machen den Link zum
Volkswagen economy Service gibt's in der
Videobeschreibung und ich bin damit raus